can we talk about danny boy hustle hard
getting antonio brown from the stadium
dude i was dying let me recap very
quickly for those who don't pay
attention to sports antonio brown is a
well-known athlete probably one of the
better receivers in the nfl right now uh
he's had a number of incidents over the
last couple of years uh and so people
are paying attention to what the hell is
going on with antonio brown plays for
the tempe buccaneers they're playing the
new york jets this weekend and in the
middle of the game antonio brown took
off his jersey and his football pads
threw him on the ground took his helmet
off then in the middle of the game ran
to the locker room with no shirt on
tossing his gloves his shirt etc into
the stands dancing in the end zone and
he basically quit he just quit in the
middle of the game uh went to the locker
room of course that wasn't the end of
the story he then called facetimed our
boy danny boy hustle hard and many of
you probably remember we brought him on
the show we're big big fans danny boy
also hard runs new york city and when he
called him danny said don't worry i got
you man i'll be there danny boy also
hard went there he is he went and he
picked up antonio brown from the stadium
in the middle of the game come on baby
come on baby
and all of a sudden
my phone started exploding because
people started saying wait a second
antonio brown got picked up by danny boy
hustle hard pat mcafee was tweeting
about all these people started tweeting
about it and joe and i started i called
joe and i just said hey bro davey boy
all sahara is blowing up right now he
don't mess around he he was uh he was
getting some press inquiries last night
i heard oh was he yeah i think uh i saw
barstool had him on their podcast like
for an episode today i'm sure a bunch of
other people hit him up i bet pat hit
him up
he picked up a b and posting videos and
was going viral all over the internet so
people were obviously uh uh trying to
see what happened john what'd you think
when you saw it i love it i thought that
photo of him they were like oh he's
waiting for an uber and he put it up he
said knives waiting on me cheech
here we go here's past tweets a new
character's been added to the a b story
dude's cutting promos kind of killing it
and then we go go down to the uh the
second tweet if we can the second tweet
this is where i this is the big one that
also i was like wait what's going on he
said hatted man danny boy also hard
high-end driver in the new york city
area danny would be offended by high-end
driver he would say i run this city joe
and uh pomp said this dude got them to a
place and half the time he would
normally take in manhattan he may or may
not run every red light from what i
heard and is hilariously bullshits the
entire trip
facts almost an accurate assessment yes
all of that is true and the great gift
usage right here by pat as well just
zipping in and out of traffic cars are a
little bit more modern but still just
getting to wherever we need to go so i
think that uh danny boy is having a a
very uh busy day today i tried already i
see some people uh putting it in the
chat i already tried to get antonio
brown on the show we've been
unsuccessful so far if we get him on the
show we will let you guys know obviously
uh but to have a little conversation
with antonio brown right now would be
very interesting you know i'd love to
see if he owns bitcoin or not my
question is how much you think uh danny
boyd could get for going on like news
media outlets right now i bet that if he
had not they were showing that video on
good morning america this morning
today's show or something like that
was on good morning america yes but but
here's the thing is if he hadn't posted
that video and he had gone to tmz and he
tried to sell it i bet she could have
got 100 g's
oh really yeah
yeah probably but the question is
yeah 100 g's might be a little high
because av wasn't doing anything in it
but like i don't know dude usually it's
like but he went viral so like yeah but
it went viral yeah whatever everybody's
gonna know danny boy hustle hard by the
end of this week yeah appreciate him